gods will be watching isn't quite like
any game I've played before you play it
like a point-and-click adventure but
it's not about solving the kinds of
puzzles you usually find in such games
instead gods will be watching is a
science fiction thriller that puts you
in incredibly high-stakes situations
where the tension is so thick as to be
almost uncomfortable lives hang in the
balance and there are about a million
ways things can go wrong at any moment
consider the first chapter a hostage
situation in which you and the other
members of your resistance group are
trying to hack into a computer belonging
to the holistic Empire you've got four
hostages to manage and enemy soldiers
advancing on your position if any
hostage gets too relaxed he or she will
think you're distracted and make a run
for it if they get too nervous they'll
panic and also make a run for it
either way it's bad news for them but
it's bad news for you to run out of
hostages and the enemy soldiers will
blast their way in every time you take
an action the mood of the hostages
shifts and you need to pay close
attention to their animations to
determine how they're feeling you've
also got to keep the guards at bay and
you've also got a computer to hack and
you've got to regularly reinforce your
network security so that the Empire's
hacker can't counter hack you and cost
you valuable hacking progress it's a lot
of plates to keep spinning and the fact
that people start dying if things go
sideways makes this first chapter a real
pressure cooker the second chapter is
more unpleasant it's a prolonged torture
sequence in which you need to survive
session after session of punishment by
alternating between successfully lying
to your captors provoking them begging
them for mercy and maybe confessing the
occasional detail you have to take the
methods your captors are using to
torture you into account to determine
just how much punishment you can take
since some things hurt a lot more than
others despite the low level of detail
in the graphics I squirm uncomfortably
in my seat every time my characters are
tortured and one round of torture is a
game of Russian roulette in which every
pull of
trigger translates into a chance that
your character's head will be blown off
it's emotionally grueling I guess I
can't complain too much
my characters suffer and die and while I
cringe uncomfortably in sympathy I'm
sitting here comfortably at my computer
but still something about this game
leaves my spirit feeling a little broken
I admire the originality of gods will be
watching but when I meet a brutal end
after suffering through session after
session of digital torture I need to
take some time to recover before jumping
back in and trying it again the gods may
be watching but they're not going to
show you any mercy they're just sitting
in quiet judgment of your every decision
the game will be released for PC on July
24th
you